don't get my little cheat sheet out how
you guys doing good all right so I
already got my emotion out before this
started when they were talking just
presenting all the statuette right the
beginning this Ward show I started you
know cheering up and it's all because
I'm gonna hopefully I got it up out of
my system I hope I don't tear up right
now but it's all because of my wife um
she may me I I don't know she do this I
know but I know she is yes okay she is
this um she's the strongest woman I know
she's made me the man I am today she's
put up with a lot of stuff a lot of
especially in the making of this film um
she means the world to me and this world
this this award goes to her just because
it's it's yes I'll stop there I didn't
she I love you okay um very important um
the next person I would like to think is
my father-in-law he's the smartest man I
know he's my mentor and I funny I'm
getting emotional but more about him um
uh um um he he maybe the artist I am
today uh he he's taught me more than
having more than anything any person I
know about art about being a man and you
know what it's a word that goes to him
as well help them I apologize i love you
Lily but uh but as you could tell it he
means a lot to me so you may have heard
my mom earlier when I was talking she
you know chat it out to me so I would
like to thank her for inspire aspiring
the rebel and me she's very proud Cuban
woman and she I want to be Who I am
of course to without her being just you
know she goes against the grain if you
ever meet her you probably will meet her
tonight she had a you know but a better
seat than I did you know she fought her
way to the front she's you know the
proudest mother that you you know that
you that's ever been created haha very
much so um so um and so I would like to
thank my father um for so much he's um
he's you know but hardest-working man
that I know he's you know he had a very
hard life I very and I just want to put
that out there he's um okay I'm not
going I'm not reading my list I'm going
off on a tangent here but but um I just
he's always been very supportive he's my
number-one fan and I want him to know
that I'm his number one fan and this is
an inside joke but he'll like it he'll
watch it on internet later we okay
yeah he's busting up right now in the
future when he watches it so okay so
onto my friends uh I would like to thank
post neo Dada it's a kind of film
collective I started six years ago and
it's still going today um I kind of had
a resurgent when I went to the Dave
Lynch masters in film program and
actually one of the members is here
today I hope he's here yet I don't know
burnaby is here postino data guy all
right cool um i would like to thank Jeff
McGuire he's actually my screenwriting
mentor he's been very helpful with my
career and he gave me a very important
mantra which is keep going and I you
know I all you winners here tonight you
know keep going there's no reason to
quit we got this you know we got this so
very important um i would like to think
joanna plasticky actually because she
for believing in me she gave me a full
scholarship to the David Lynch film
program and that you know that's that's
changed my life it really I was at a
very very low moment and it really got
me out of it and it's been nothing but
up from there and does you know bear it
she deserves a thank you for sure and
John rots actually is here as well from
the program and he's you know done a
great job elevating that program and
he's he's helped me he's gonna continue
to help me at right I hope so yes thank
you he's shown my work too I'm not going
to name who it is but a huge hero of
mine and you know that's just it's very
surreal that all this is happening and I
just all the support I can get please
keep helping me all right I'd like to
thank David Lynch for you know having
this program for being the artist he is
one of the most influential artists to
me for sure as you may have saw it's
very strange I mean it's very you know
the cell my maid and and I just he's
just such a master he so much himself
and you know and he also is highly into
meditation transcendental meditation and
he has done a lot of great work with his
foundation for at-risk students and
veterans and just you know he's a really
great man and I would love to keep
hanging out with them I feel like
happening um here we are so now we're to
the Academy uh thanks to the Academy
check off my list you know bucket list
very awesome um I haha I'm I'm a massive
film nerd so to be a part of to you know
to go to the film vault and to be
invited to go back and to go the
screenings I mean it's going to be fun I
can't wait to take advantage of this and
in particular this week Shaun Hector
Brian James and Mary I forgive do forget
any of that anyone else who helped me
this week but it's you guys made an
incredible week I I was sitting at
dinner recently next to this deana
director and I just cannot get the smile
with my face because you know this and
he was just tell him he was giving me
this you know beaver be rebellious fine
your voice and it's just like it's such
so refreshing to have to hear that from
an Academy member i believe is a first
Latino Academy member that's also very
cool i could be wrong but i'm pretty
sure you said that and so that was it's
been a very special week and i thank you
so much every got every all you guys on
to the winners all you guys yes you guys
are amazing go ahead clap plays please
clap for them
you guys it's been so fun naturally you
know it's we're so excited and it's such
an honor to be a part of all the films
you guys made I mean really it's been a
was a credible very long but it wasn't
very very incredible to watch all the
films and it's very much so an honor to
be among them um okay my wife told me
not to do this but I'm gonna do it okay
so now she's gonna hate you later okay
so I have a massive crowd on the
filmmaker I need to promote myself okay
I have a world premiere tomorrow at the
lammle theater you got to hear it you
have to hear it okay no laughing okay
the the lammle music hall three across
the street is playing my brand new film
at noon tomorrow that's going to be
playing there all week so I encourage
you guys to come out hope you like it
okay moving on okay okay and so here's
my thank you haha and here's my final
story um miss you know I like to thank
my grandma she got diagnosed with cancer
a couple years ago and she told me
Johnny go get her status tues macadam e
award for me excuse me no no no no go
get an Academy worked for me and you
know of course i was thinking yeah yes
whatever yeah you know i'll do my best
that's all i ever do um you know so the
good news is she's you know beat that
cancer and I wouldn't Academy Award of
word from the Academy so there you go
grandma alright thanks guys